[Music]
the different side of clipart that you
haven't seen important and what we're
going to explore corners in the universe
that might be untouched which is really
exciting I am burdened with glorious one
of the biggest questions that audiences
had coming out of the game is where did
you go this series will answer that
everything about one division is that we
get to see what an ideal life for one
vision actually looks like
[Music]
we're gonna make the first scary and see
you bill
ten rings has been in the MCU since the
very beginning
the internals are the really special
group of people that will feel different
than anything we've done before
[Music]
this show is going to be about two
characters that has become simply spam
favorites
complicated
in duration they get to play Natasha
as a fully realized woman
[Music]
because she was
[Music]
we're continuing the legacy of the MCU
and we're going to do that in new ways
unexpected ways and really build on the
legacy of what's come before
[Music]
[Music]